then the character got some buffs right
they gave the new low everything they
made the down by two safe round blocks
and now we didn't really see a lot of
negan's get picked up but sure enough
now we're starting to see them making
waves in tournaments so uh it's very
cool to see negan you know kind of uh
flourishing now as the seasons progress
yeah if if they gave negan um
much better low popes and better
tracking negan would really be top tier
but
we don't want that especially if we are
on the receiving end of that but negan
right now is is it is okay but if he
were given more low post rather than
just down four down back four down back
two he'd he'd be a more decent character
than he is now
i think he's fine i don't think he'll
want to give him any more loads i think
so too down back forward counter hit bro
that's so that's such a good situation
for him you know i think he's fine
uh but definitely i think a character
that a lot of people don't have as much
experience with you know it's he's been
out for for years now but people weren't
using it in tournament especially right
so you didn't really have to worry about
it like your top 8 competitor you're
like i'm not going to play against the
against the negan you know like why
would i worry about negan when i got
[ __ ] wrong and leroy and lydia and
cooney mitchell to worry about but now
he's enough of a threat that you're
paying attention
yeah for sure so now we're gonna get
into the match here i believe it is
going to be
tomorrow versus rgn and we talked about
this earlier
does have a noctis
street fighter versus final fantasy
incoming year at the tekken online
challenge 2021 top eight akuma versus
noctis not a matchup that i get to see a
ton
but it sounds pretty cool to be honest
did the fireballs and his like his uh i
want to say he's kunai do they do they
trade or they just go through each other
does he teleport through the fireball
like i don't even know what happened
that interaction
they go through each other but the thing
is noctis still rolls towards his enemy
so i i don't think if he hit her up
whatsoever
no he doesn't i want to see it oh okay
okay i'll be sick oh boy he wanted to
find out himself orders a bait
all right that down two is so good it's
gonna happen
yeah
oh my gosh again another low parry from
summary roof falls up to the combo oh he
misses the fm beautiful coming in rgn
gets finished off
the perfect nicely done tomorrow
looking really clear the knockouts you
know sidestepping or back dashing out of
the way up to get a kick there uh just
so smart just let it work got the
perfect aura there
and just really looking sharp in this
akuma match-up
up
up forward once it works like a steve
back one pretty good i love it
is it up forward not back right you can
do it like in multiple directions i
think
that's a weird move because i don't know
which way to call it ever yeah yeah
appreciate you doing this up back one
two
oh god i never knew that but hey the
more you know
yep nice try go for low spear and you
know that time the highest rate rgn
he's ready for it let's go
on the board here
all right uh tomorrow been on fire with
these slow parries lately and now he's
gonna go for the oki combo aura coming
in there's no way akima can punish that
unless it's a point black rage and he
can get the ff21 in
yeah that seems really hard to do
and you know the other thing you know i
think tomorrow we see a ton of low
praise now just because of the last that
we saw with him versus ak right he's
like i can't believe i got hit by a
billion lows i'm low pairing everything
from now on
he's trying to redeem myself at this
point you know he's looking for a low
parry rj is getting scared at this point
oh he didn't go for it
hey
not i'm here to make that hurt more but
the down four is a good follow round
four
there it is
rgn taking it to a round three he's
potentially one round left tomorrow back
to such a good move for noctis
yeah it's ridiculous
especially on the internet
get the combo conversion
stop no
no ender but it kind of leaves them out
of rage so it's not actually the worst
drop
dunk and something and something about
it is also that something about this
matchup is when rgn recklessly jumps oh
my goodness the running oneplus 2
catches our dan off the yard so yeah
back to the point that if rgm
jumps tomorrow can capture the 2-2 and
he can continue off with the combo like
that so it's a big advantage for
tomorrow in this case
yeah that's probably why he picked the
noctis specifically right because he
knew he was going to be going against
the kuma here
oh man look at my damage those
downforces oh
combo conversion beautiful keep it
simple
by rgn follows up with the combo but he
misses
again i wonder why is that
i mean it wasn't gonna do too much but
again the drop works out leaves him out
of range but this could be enough
and it is rgn round one against tomorrow
so a lot of hiccups from tomorrow there
you know um
uh
i i personally think he liked a lot of
offense but rgn just capitalized on
whatever there was for him
with them with the meters and all he's
used them to use his advantage pretty
good
yeah i was actually surprised it really
looked like tomorrow had controlled the
match from the get-go but as it went on
you know rgn just stayed consistent he's
like all right i've been low paired a
billion times but you know what i'm
gonna go with these downforce the
downforce really started opening things
up for him uh the combos were hitting
this time you know we saw a lot of the
common drops from the fadcs earlier but
this time all the comments are coming
together he missed a couple of the
enders but really as i mentioned they
were kind of good to miss because it
left not just out of rage you don't have
to worry about the rage drive hitting
you randomly when you're full speed
expect on the infinite stage uh so those
drops actually were kind of beneficial
yeah taking a page out of ak's book you
know rgn
down four after count four after down
four he knew he was effective against uh
you know he knew it was effective in
that ak versus tomorrow match
and now he's doing it himself and fun
fact rgn actually trains a lot with uh
with ak
back when you know the things were still
normal around the world they're
training buddies uh as you call it
we can we can we can see a lot here so
let's see if rgn can keep it up
whoa okay the king coming out this time
for tomorrow we've seen a bunch of
characters today is this the fourth
character we've seen from him i feel
like it is uh but i'm excited to see
this king
versus akuma
should be an issue when i have yet to
see his king so i'm excited to see when
you bring to the table here
let's see if tomorrow can stay in the
tournament this is losers bracket action
top eight
here at tekken online challenge
philippines and east asia
wow that was so cheap man he's a power
question come on
we all saw it here we go
rgn's got the momentum already we're
only 10 seconds in tomorrow is put in
rage and rgs only got one more mix-up
until he can take tomorrow out in this
round one down three seven golden letter
foot
perfectly gold that time you know
tomorrow started the first game off for
the perfect rgn answered back game two
round one
oh my gosh should we go for a double
perfect
we might are we gonna see a god match
here potentially oh dude you can't save
that early
[Music]
14 golden letters are we going for it
are we going to go back jump no jump oh
my god we might get a gun oh god man get
it out of here get it out of here you
got me all excited kid
i mean it would have been perfect i mean
you were in that one match where it was
a perfect you know uh three perfects in
a row but
all right tomorrow time to bring it all
the way back now
you gotta duck those man i'm telling you
one of these days he's gonna block him
but rgn closes it out three two oh sweep
and eliminates tomorrow again here we
have rgn proceeding to the bracket
amazing performance by rgm
exactly very nicely done there the
double perfect to start it off you know
anytime you do that to an opponent
tournament they are broken uh right and
you know there was a chance you know
tomorrow gets that round you can turn
everything around still but it's so hard
right like everything is stacked and
gets you momentum wise uh rough start
there for tomorrow in game two and
really cost him out of tournament fifth
place that's a great showing